hey this is press tow
Walker in this video I'll present three
puzzles about finding the length in the
given
figure problem one a right triangle has
legs that are equal to four and
six a semicircle has its Center on the
hypotenuse and is tangent to both
legs what is the radius of the
semicircle equal to I thank isou from
Bangladesh for the
suggestion
problem two the world needs you right
now two countries are feuding over a
mountain
range they tell you that if you can just
figure out the length of the base of
this mountain range it will help the two
countries come to peace this is for
reasons beyond your intelligence
clearance due to geopolitical reasons
you can't directly measure the length of
the base but you are able to come up
with some other
measurements this first first slant is
six the next is five the next is four
and the last is three this vertical
distance is 10 you are also able to come
up with some angles this first angle is
45° each of these is a right angle this
is a 45° angle and this final angle is
90° your mission should you choose to
accept it is to calculate the value of
x I think m from the Czech Republic for
submitting a problem which inspired this
puzzle problem three we have two circles
that are tangent to each other construct
parallel lines between them now
construct a small circle that's tangent
to the two large circles and one of the
parallel lines then do the same thing on
the other parallel
line if the distance between the centers
of the two small circles is equal to 96
what is the distance between the centers
of the two large
circles this is from the
2016 Bangladesh mathematical
Olympiad pause the video if you'd like
to give these problems a try and when
you're ready keep watching to learn how
to solve these
[Music]
problems let's solve problem one we will
derive a general formula
suppose the right triangle has legs that
are equal to a and b we will prove that
R is equal to a divided A+ B in other
words R is half the harmonic mean of A
and B this formula can also be Rewritten
as 1 / R is equal to 1 A + 1/
B let's see why this is true the area of
the right triangle is equal to 12 a * B
we are now going to calculate the area
of the right triangle in another way
construct one radius to the point of
tangent C on the leg with side length a
this will have a length that's equal to
R we then construct another radius to
the other point of tangent C we
construct the following triangle we have
a base a and we have the height upon the
base a that's equal to R so this
triangle's area will be equal to 12 R *
a
then we have another triangle here and
the area of this triangle will be equal
to 12 * R * B so we have 12 a * B is
equal to 1 12 R * a + 1 12 R * B
canceling the 1/ 12 terms on both sides
and factoring on the right hand side we
get that AB is equal to R multiplied by
a plus b dividing both sides by a plus b
we get that R is equal to a / a plus b
B we then take the reciprocal of both
sides and then divide through by AB to
get that 1 / R is equal to 1 a + 1 over
B so now let's solve the original
problem we had a is equal to 4 and B is
equal to 6 so R is equal to 4 * 6 / 4 +
6 this equals 24 10 which simplifies to
be 12 over 5 which equals
2.4 and that's the answer
now let's solve problem two you think
about the problem for a while and you
remember some high school geometry which
will help you first extend the line
marked five then construct a
perpendicular so that you form a
rectangle opposite sides of the
rectangle are equal to each other so
this length is also equal to
six then you extend the three line then
construct another perpendicular to form
another
rectangle opposite sides of this
rectangle are equal to each other so
this length is also equal to
four now we formed some right
triangles this is a
454590 right triangle if one side is X
the other side is also equal to X and
the hypotenuse is equal to x * < tk2 so
the other leg is also equal to six and
the hypotenuse is equal to 6 < tk2 this
is another
454590 right triangle so this leg is
also equal to four and this hypotenuse
will be equal to 4 <
tk2 finally we have a final
454590 right triangle so the other leg
is equal to
10 the base is the sum of these
distances and that means that X is equal
to 10 + 10 < tk2 which is approximately
equal to 24
.14 you submit this information to your
Superior and this little bit of
information helps the two countries come
to piece and you've done a great
service now let's solve problem
three we'll first review a principle if
two circles A and B are tangent to each
other and they have a tangent Point T
their centers and the tangent Point T
are
cinear to do this draw a line through
the tangent Point T then a t will be
perpendicular to the tangent line BT
will be perpendicular to the tangent
line and therefore ATB will be a
straight line segment this is true for
both externally and internally tangent
circles so now let's solve the
problem let's first say the radius of
the large circle is equal to a and the
radius of each of the small circles is
equal to B
now the diameter of the large Circle
will be equal to 2
a now this will also be equal to B so
now the distance between the two small
circle centers will be 2 A minus 2 B and
that is given to be 96 so we have 2 Aus
2 B is equal to
96 now the distance between the centers
of the two large circles will be equal
to a plus a so we need to solve for 2 a
to do this we will construct a right
triangle like this the hypotenuse will
have a length that's equal to a plus b
and then the other leg will be equal to
a minus B so we have a 2 plus the square
of a minus B is equal to the square of a
+ b so now let's just focus on these two
equations from the first equation divide
both sides by two so we have a minus B
isal Al to 48 we'll then solve for b to
get that b is equal to a -
48 we can substitute both of these into
the other equation so a minus B is equal
to 48 and then we'll substitute B is
equal to a minus
48 so we have a^ 2 + 48 2 is equal to
the square of a + b we substitute in for
B then we
simplify we expand the
binomial we then
simplify and we can then factor out an
a now a cannot be equal to zero that's
the radius of the large circles so we
have 3 Aus 192 is equal to 0 which means
a is equal to
64 we just go back to the original
diagram now we need it to solve for 2 a
so 2 a is equal to
128 and that's the answer
thanks for making us one of the best
communities on YouTube see you next
episode of mind your decisions where we
solve The World's problems one video at
a
time